Alors, vous êtes très
nombreux et nombreuses
à m'avoir demandé
de traiter un sujet en particulier,
c'est celui du conflit
entre Israël et la Palestine.
Et en fait, vous avez
complètement raison
parce que c’est un sujet
qui est super important
et dont on ne parle plus beaucoup
alors que les tensions sont
toujours aussi vives sur place.
Alors, j’ai sauté dans un avion
pour me rendre à Jérusalem
qui est vraiment la ville symbole de ce conflit.
Jérusalem, c’est une ville
qui a plus de 5000 ans d’histoire
et c’est aussi la ville sainte
des 3 religions du Livre,
donc le judaïsme, le christianisme et l’islam.
Alors, cette ville, elle est coupée
en deux depuis les années 1940.
Alors, pour faire très, très simple,
d'un côté, à l'ouest,
il y a des Israéliens juifs,
et de l'autre, à l’est, des Palestiniens musulmans.
En réalité, c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça.
Et c'est bien ça,
le problème.
Pour les Palestiniens comme pour les Israéliens,
Jérusalem, c'est leur capitale.
Et c'est de là que vient
une grande partie des tensions.
Depuis plus de 50 ans,
les Israéliens, ils grignotent
de plus en plus
de territoires à Jérusalem-Est,
donc les territoires palestiniens.
Ça continue encore aujourd'hui.
Et dans la plupart des cas,
en fait, les maisons des Palestiniens
sont rachetées par des organisations juives.
Et les autorités israéliennes
ensuite expulsent de force
les familles palestiniennes
qui y vivent
pour que des familles juives
viennent s'y installer.
Et l'ONU considère que Jérusalem-Est
est un territoire occupé illégalement.
La communauté internationale
a de nombreuses fois condamné l'État d'Israël.
Mais en réalité, ça ne
change pas grand-chose.
Alors, je suis allée à Jérusalem
en plein mois du ramadan,
c'est un mois où il y a généralement
beaucoup de tensions
entre la communauté juive
et musulmane,
pour comprendre un petit peu
comment ça se passait sur place.
Donc là, ça fait déjà plusieurs fois
que je peux voir des arrestations
qui sont hyper calmes,
mais assez étranges, parce qu'en fait,
on voit les forces de l'ordre israéliennes
qui sortent de leur poste de police
et qui se baladent et qui choisissent
quelqu'un un peu au hasard,
qui est assis tranquillement.
Ils l'embarquent, ils le fouillent,
et ensuite, ils le libèrent au bout
de quelques minutes.
Donc, on a l'impression que
c'est un petit peu pour
entretenir la peur aussi
parmi les jeunes.
Sur les réseaux sociaux,
il y a des vidéos qui sont hyper populaires,
qui font des centaines de milliers
voire des millions de vues parfois,
où il y a des jeunes Palestiniens
qui provoquent les Israéliens
et la police.
Lors du ramadan
de l'année dernière,
il y a cette vidéo TikTok
d'un adolescent palestinien
qui gifle un jeune israélien religieux
dans le tramway de Jérusalem
qui avait mené à une escalade
de violence complètement dingue.
En fait, cette vidéo de la gifle,
elle va être utilisée comme argument
par des groupes radicaux juifs
pour appeler à se venger
ensuite sur des Palestiniens.
Et sur les réseaux, ces vidéos
de représailles, elles sont partout.
En Israël comme en Palestine,
en fait, tout le monde filme
tout le temps,
soit pour accuser,
soit pour provoquer l'autre camp.
Alors là, je me trouve dans
le quartier de Silwan,
qui est un des quartiers
résidentiels de Jérusalem-Est
qui est considéré
comme un territoire occupé.
Et en fait, ici se déroule
une véritable guerre de territoires.
En fait, il y a plus d'une
centaine de familles palestiniennes
qui vivent ici
depuis des générations
qui sont menacées
d'expulsion
pour être remplacées
par des familles de colons juifs.
Ces expulsions, elles sont
considérées totalement illégales
par la communauté
internationale.
Mais les familles juives,
qui sont souvent
des familles
ultra-orthodoxes,
elles considèrent que
ces terres leurs appartiennent
et que Jérusalem est
la capitale d'Israël.
Il y a des expulsions
de familles palestiniennes
quasiment tous les mois.
Et ces expulsions, en fait,
elles sont appuyées par
des décisions de justice israéliennes.
Alors, il y a beaucoup de lois
qui sont utilisées
dans ces cas-là,
mais il y a surtout une loi
qui en fait permet
à un juif de réclamer
la propriété d'un terrain
dont ses ancêtres
ont été expulsés lors de
la création de l'État d'Israël,
donc à l'époque où la ville
de Jérusalem a été coupée en deux.
Mais en fait, ce qu'il
faut savoir, c'est que cette loi,
elle ne s'applique
qu'aux juifs
et pas aux arabes
qui, eux, en fait, ne peuvent
pas réclamer les terres
dont leurs aînés ont été expulsés,
eux aussi, à ce moment-là, en 1948.
J'ai essayé d'interviewer certains
de ces Israéliennes et de ces Israéliens
qui vivent dans ce quartier pour avoir un petit peu leur vision des choses.
En fait, ils étaient tous hyper réticents à parler devant ma caméra.
Alors, j'ai tenté du coup ma chance avec une caméra plus discrète, plus petite,
qui impressionne moins les gens.
Et après beaucoup de refus,
il y a finalement un habitant
qui a accepté de me parler.
Au final, j’ai réussi à avoir
rendez-vous avec Daniel Luria.
Alors, c'est un homme
qui est très médiatique,
qui est le porte-parole d’une association
de colons israéliens
qui milite pour l’installation
de familles juives à Jérusalem-Est,
donc dans les quartiers qui sont considérés
par la communauté internationale
comme occupés.
Alors, derrière moi, en fait,
vous pouvez voir l’immense mur
qui sépare Israël de la Palestine.
Là, je suis du côté palestinien,
et ça, c’est un des nombreux
checkpoints
qui permet de passer à Jérusalem.
Comme on est vendredi,
aujourd’hui, en fait,
y a plein de Palestiniens
qui veulent se rendre à la mosquée al-Aqsa
pour aller prier.
Alors, cette année, les autorités israéliennes ont fait une règle un petit peu spéciale.
En fait, tous les hommes de plus de 50 ans
et les femmes de plus de 45 ans,
normalement, ont le droit de passer
ce checkpoint sans autorisation spéciale.
En réalité, c’est un peu plus
compliqué que ça,
parce qu’hier soir, il y a eu
un attentat terroriste, à Tel-Aviv,
qui a fait deux morts.
Donc, ça a vraiment tendu
la situation.
Là, je me trouve devant l’une des 11 portes
qui mènent à la mosquée al-Aqsa.
Donc, la mosquée al-Aqsa, c’est quand même
un des trois lieux saints dans l’islam.
Donc, en fait, pendant le ramadan,
il y a parfois, certains jours,
près de 100 000 personnes
qui viennent prier ici.
Il y a des policiers israéliens
devant chaque porte,
qui contrôlent un peu
les entrées et les sorties...
Donc, là, justement, on peut voir
qu’il y a pas mal de tensions
et de clashs entre les gens.
Il y a quelqu’un qui vient de se faire arrêter,
je ne sais pas exactement pourquoi,
par la police israélienne,
quelqu’un qui se rendait à la mosquée.
Y a les policiers israéliens
qui me demandent d’arrêter de filmer.
Juste avant que cet homme
se fasse arrêter,
j’étais en train de vous dire, justement,
qu’il y a des policiers israéliens
devant chacune des portes
qui mènent à la mosquée
et y a même
un commissariat à l’intérieur,
avec, parfois,
des patrouilles de police israéliennes
pendant les prières,
et ça, ça crée énormément
de tension.
Quand on se balade, dans la
vieille ville de Jérusalem,
y a un truc qui est vraiment très frappant,
c’est qu’on voit
des forces de l’ordre israéliennes
vraiment à tous les coins de rue.
En fait, ce qu’il faut savoir,
c’est qu’il y a eu trois attentats
juste avant le mois du ramadan
et du coup, le gouvernement israélien
a annoncé
qu’il déploierait plus de
3000 policiers dans la ville.
Donc, vraiment, là,
on le ressent énormément.
Donc, là, on voit qu’il y a énormément
de personnes
qui sont en train de se diriger
vers la mosquée,
parce que c’est la prière principale
du vendredi.
Donc, y a quand même pas mal de gens
qui ont réussi à traverser les checkpoints.
Y a vraiment des gens de toute la Palestine
qui sont venus pour aller prier.
On va les suivre un petit peu,
pour voir à quoi ça ressemble.
La mosquée al-Aqsa, elle est au centre
de toutes les tensions à Jérusalem.
En fait, il y a très régulièrement
des affrontements sur l’esplanade.
L’année dernière, ces affrontements
ont mené à une guerre de onze jours
entre Israël et Gaza.
Et cette année, les incidents recommencent.
La raison de ces tensions,
c’est que pour les musulmans,
c’est un des lieux les plus sacrés de l’islam,
mais pour les juifs aussi.
Car en fait, ils appellent l'endroit
le mont du Temple
en souvenir à un temple juif
détruit à l'époque romaine
qui était exactement sur ce lieu.
Le conflit israélo-palestinien dure
depuis plus de 70 ans,
et franchement, c’est impossible de tout
vous raconter dans une seule vidéo
tant le sujet est ultra-complexe.
Si certains ou certaines d’entre vous veulent creuser un peu plus ce sujet en profondeur,
je vous mets des liens en description
pour aller plus loin.
J’espère que la vidéo vous a plu
et que vous avez appris des choses.
Si c’est le cas, n’hésitez pas à vous abonner,
à partager et à commenter.
Et je vous dis à très bientôt !